so we need to chat again hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
i did want to pop in here again because
the other week
i uploaded a video about me not
identifying myself
as a body positive dietitian that i
subsequently
removed and a lot of you reached out to
me after the fact telling me that you
really loved the video
and you agreed with it and you wish that
i kept it up but i removed it for a few
really important reasons first of all i
just felt that it was misconstrued as a
direct response to an article that i
referenced in the video although
that was actually not my intention i
also just felt like i did a
total crap job articulating all the
angles of
this really complicated controversial
topic and i still don't really
understand
everything so this response here is
really just going to build on my
knowledge but it's ultimately just a
series of questions more than anything
and is not really me trying to suggest
that i have this stuff figured out
because i don't i also actually feel
really bad because it did appear in the
video that i threw my colleague john
from obese to beast under the bus
and that really was never my intention i
mentioned
in my video that he struggled reading
the article that i referenced on his
live youtube video
not knowing that he has a learning
disability but the only reason i even
said that
and it was an off the cuff remark was
really just to point out how
challenging the article was for all of
us hence why i mentioned myself that i
read it like a million times
and i still didn't digest at all john
read and responded to it
live and that is honestly something
quite amazing and not something that i
could do
but john is a really intelligent guy and
i respect him a lot so
of course it was a rude off-the-cuff
statement that
came out totally wrong and i did
apologize to him both publicly and
privately
and he's actually going to pop in
shortly to chat so stay tuned for that
but ultimately
i just feel like in general i didn't
check my blind spots which i am really
upset and disappointed and ashamed about
because i generally try really hard to
do that but i think it just shows me how
much work i have
to do still when this was not
necessarily all top of mind for me
and i realized that i have the privilege
for not
to be top of mind when for so many
others
this stuff is always on their mind so
i'm working really hard to change that
so thank you as always for the helpful
reminder
so i want to share with you a lot of the
thoughts from
that previous video verbatim again but
also insert a few additional
considerations and clarifications
throughout this attempt also includes
some conversations with some larger
bodied and bipoc friends of mine
to hopefully bring their perspectives to
the picture
ultimately i think that these
conversations are going to be scary
and uncomfortable and not easy that's
probably why i unconsciously just didn't
tease
some of these more difficult topics
apart in my original
video attempt probably because i was
unconsciously kind of scared of messing
up and
being called out for it but i realized
that i'm okay
with being called out if that means that
i learned something from the process you
know it's all part of this messy
learning experience of helping us
better understand inequalities in this
world so ultimately i am putting myself
out there to your criticism knowing that
even with a redo
i will inevitably still mess up i will
still probably not see all of my
privilege and i will use the wrong words
and not get it right but i'm willing to
take that chance and open myself up to
the scrutiny to
hold a place here for this really
important dialogue so let's talk
about a month ago while i was doing my
pseudo mat leave
i read an article called the unbearable
whiteness and fat phobia of anti-diet
dietitians
by marc riselle mercedes and it really
kept me up at night basically this essay
suggested that
white straight sized aka thin anti-diet
dietitians
were appropriating the body positive
movement for their own financial gain
in the original video i read off a
really long excerpt from
the article but i do encourage you guys
to read the article
yourself so in an interest in time and
to try to keep this video succinct
i'm going to shorten the quote a bit but
you can of course read it below so the
quote was
i'm mad at the anti-die dietitians adds
that sit in their photos to show their
stomach
read skin folds i'm mad at the adds that
feign
eating desserts or pizza or something
equally demonized
for pictures that they post with
captions like no foods are bad or
you don't have to work out to earn food
i'm mad at the adds who say that you can
still love your body
and want it to be smaller i'm absolutely
pissed at the adds
who stand in their mirrors or on the
beach to display
their minor bloating or the small
dimples in their thighs
the white hot rage i feel when these
women tell me to flaunt my body
that i'm still sexy no matter my size
because they're sexy at their size in
the position that they feel fattest in
if you are an anti-diet dietitian and
you do any of these things
brand my words into your mind you are
diet culture by portraying your
miniature roles and
folds as things to love despite their
existence
despite the way they distance you from
perfection
you are not only saying that my fat body
is inherently
worse than yours but you are
subliminally communicating
that rolls and folds are only okay
and normal and sexy on a body like yours
so thin so white so unbearably
conventional
again please read the full article which
i'm going to be linking below but
i thought i would share some of my
thoughts with you i'm being totally
transparent that i have not
figured this all out yet i'm literally
still in talks with myself
as a person and as a professional about
where i stand
in this really messy world of dietetics
but i'm human
and i'm not perfect and i would really
love to hear your thoughts in response
to mine
so let's have a can of conversation in
my previous video i referenced the body
positivity movement and fat acceptance
movement
together stating that it was started by
black women in the 1960s
to encourage women to celebrate their
body as it is
without shame while also advocating for
more equal treatment of
fat bodies now this past week however i
did do some additional
digging on this and what i realized was
that the body positivity movement and
fat acceptance movement
are not one in the same body positivity
movement was actually birthed
from the fat acceptance movement of the
1960s the fat acceptance movement
focused on the culture of fat shaming
and discrimination against people in
larger bodies now i believe that the
body positivity movement emerged much
later
possibly sometime in the late 90s or
early 2000s
to really focus on the acceptance of all
bodies regardless of
physical ability size gender race or
appearance but while it does appear that
it was started by black women
as a response to society's fear of size
and racial otherness it's since become
a movement almost solely defined on
social media
by white thin beautiful women it's also
become a massive buzzword used largely
for marketing purposes
by corporations looking to sell their
products under the guise of
inclusivity so i understand the
frustration of mark russell mercedes who
authored the article that i quoted
it's totally understandable that she
would feel edged out of
a movement designed to uplift a certain
population
who are now once again kind of pushed
the sidelines
meanwhile white thin privileged women
like me are left to benefit from the
cause and that's not fair
i don't want to all lives matter a
concept that i really do think
is so important because if it's
important to me it's surely
so important to the people living in the
bodies for whom it was built
to serve so i do believe that i need to
make more space for that
and if that means avoiding the use of
the body positive hashtag for my own
promotion
while still supporting its tenants i
think that makes absolute sense
side note i will just say that i
actually don't think i've ever
necessarily referred to myself as a body
positive dietitian
and i am very much aware and hesitant to
share photos of my body
or discuss my body in general without
like a million disclaimers knowing
that it's definitely a privileged body
but still i do think i may be guilty of
this
indirectly or unconsciously or somehow
by association with my ties to
intuitive eating so that brings me to a
question that
i've been asking myself with regards to
this whole body positivity isn't for
thin
white women issue and before i get into
this list of questions that i had asked
in my previous video
just a reminder that these were honest
innocent questions
i was in no way feeling attacked or
threatened by the article that i
referenced
nor the idea of me being pushed out of
the body positive space
again unlike a lot of my colleagues
i don't think that i've ever actually
publicly identified myself as a
body positive dietitian so i don't have
a whole lot to lose in giving up this
title
nor am i really defensive about that
these are just innocent questions that
come up for me
and for other white thin dietitians that
i've spoken with
while grappling with some of these
issues i'm just saying them out loud
in a ultimately very vulnerable space
knowing
that a lot of you may have these same
questions too is there a weight cut off
for
when it's okay to talk about body
positivity
what if i'm recovering from an eating
disorder and you know showing my belly
rolls for example feels like a huge
leap or accomplishment or if we look at
intersectionality
what about its use for women who are fat
but who are white or a dominant race i
don't have
answers for these but i think of this
similar to how some of you often ask me
the question
what is the cutoff for health at every
size you know at what point
does a higher weight actually become
unhealthy if you asked a haze advocate
they would probably tell you that there
is no official weight cut off and that
you would use the same counseling
methods and encourage the same health
behaviors regardless of whether or not
someone was
150 pounds or 550 pounds and that brings
me to some other questions
largely inspired by my colleague abby
langer's blog post
which again i will link below but i
often wonder you know
what is it okay to do or not to do
to exhibit body positivity so by some
people's standards
things like intentionally trying to lose
weight by dieting or exercise or having
weight loss surgery or plastic surgery
would not be acts of body positivity but
what about other ways of changing your
body like
dyeing your hair or getting eyelash
extensions or botox or
acrylic nails i guess my question is
like where is the line drawn or
is there a line period none of these are
meant to be criticisms of the movement
or concept of body positivity they're
just questions that i don't have
answers to maybe because i don't know
enough or i don't understand enough so
to ensure that my voice is not the most
dominant in this space especially
because
clearly i'm not an expert here and i'm
just a student i'm just learning
i want to ask some of my colleagues
about their perspective
so how do you define body positivity and
who
is it ultimately for feel like body
positivity has really
changed over the years when i was first
introduced to body positivity
body positivity was really for fat
individuals or it was really
taken from the fat activism movement i
think body positivity has really like
taken on like a different definition
than it had originally started so a lot
of people have asked me that
and i didn't really know that when i
picked the handle for my instagram
account it sort of like
dawned on me after i got a little bit
more popular like oh and it was really
started
by a black queer individuals a lot of
the research that has been done
to my knowledge it was started in the
late 1960s i think the thing is that it
started from an activism movement
how we see it today that's clearly not
what it is it's not an activism movement
it's more of just like
anything can be body positive i i am
existing in my body and that is body
positive what it was
in body positive that we see it in its
iteration today
are not one in the same i think body
positivity is for everyone and i define
it as i like to go back to the roots of
body positivity that came out of the fat
acceptance movement getting it back to
the marginalized groups that it was
intended for
black brown weird non-binary getting it
back to them but
originally it's for everyone but it's
really to support and to help
marginalized people people and
marginalized bodies feel like their body
is still
celebrated and feel like it has space in
society
body positivity like i hope can be like
more
inclusive and not just for like certain
you know communities or even just for
women
i think like body positivity is for
everybody
since we live in this world that's
constantly telling us that
our bodies should be a certain way and
we are not
valuable if we don't look a certain way
so i think really
everybody gets that message so i think
body positivity is for everybody even
though i specifically
speak to moms do you consider yourself
body positive
i mean i think definitely it was a
journey for me absolutely and i've been
like really vocal on instagram that i
became a dietitian
because i was so obsessed with food and
weight
i became a dietitian because i was
absolutely not body positive
no i don't only because while i have
some marginalizations i do not feel like
my body necessarily needs to be the
poster child for it i like to leave that
for people who genuinely like their body
is not celebrated within
society so people in larger bodies much
larger bodies uh people who are disabled
queer
non-married it's like their space they
need to be amplified and so i don't
necessarily need to amplify myself in
that space
i've sort of like moved away from body
positive
i don't consider myself body positive
it's not wording that i identify with
whatsoever i would say that now i
consider myself a person who identifies
with the words
body neutral and i'm for fat liberation
i consider myself body neutral because i
have good days in my body
and bad days in my body so when you say
your body positive
that means that you're positive in your
body all the time which i don't think is
a thing
that exists who is positive in their
body all the time that's just
no that's unrealistic there are days
where i'm gonna feel really
shitty in my body and there's some days
where i'm gonna feel like hey i look
awesome and great and i love the way i
like look in terms of fat liberation
it means that i am here to liberate fat
folks from the oppression that they face
day in and day out
how do you feel about influencers with
stereotypical
good bodies posting about you know
insecurities and things like that using
hashtags like hashtag bodypositive
i think it helps people who looks like
them but i think for the sum total of
movement i think it's harmful because we
understand that algorithms praise people
that are in these
sort of stereotypical thin bodies and so
it's pushing out the people who
are not celebrated and sort of
catapulting the people who are already
celebrated
the thing is is that so often these
influencers come into it with like
very good intentions i think everybody
has body image issues and i don't want
to say that like oh
these people don't have body image
issues but i think where
where the problem lies is that so often
we're trying to
pit my issues are greater than your
issue
and the thing is is that people who are
fat disabled trans
we're facing greater marginalization
than somebody who is like maybe
thin and white it really depends on the
message
because even i get comments or i read
about myself when people write about me
and saying like oh she's not even big
enough to be talking like this what do i
need to look like in order to like
promote a positive message
i think for me as a dietitian i can i
have the ability to speak more broadly
you know to this
but i do find it kind of harmful
when somebody is posting pictures that
are very filtered
muscle definition and then saying like
i'm body positive because i think you're
kind of going against
what body positivity is you know being
more of like a
natural normal
not filtered image and do you think that
the term has evolved to the point where
its original meeting is like completely
lost and it would need like a complete
major marketing campaigns bring it back
i think that it has taken on something
that it definitely wasn't intended to
take on
i think for a lot of people who are
pushing back against body positivity
they see it in more of a light as
promoting obesity
and i think that they are just so far
off with that so i think you know body
positivity still
seems to be like one of those vague
terms that people can
kind of use to you know promote whatever
message they're trying to promote
and that's what i don't love about the
term right now
i think the moment we can associate body
positivity with a brand and a particular
look
i think it's lost it's it's right and
almost to the point that body positivity
has
become an aesthetic of like oh i'm this
bopo person i like dress a certain way i
fix my coffee a certain way because
that's like a bopo thing
instead of it being like i am
celebrating the body for the fact that
it's a body and not for
the way that it looks what are the
aspects of it that you do
really like i almost feel like it's like
this rising up of like you know what
we are not going to look at these
victoria's secret models and say we need
to look like that or
our bodies don't count or like once we
become moms and we've gained weight or
we've gotten stretch marks or whatever
we've aged that all of a sudden we are
not as beautiful as the 20 year old
beach model
thank you all so much for your thoughts
i'm going to be linking
to everyone's websites and instagrams
below in case you want to check
some of these folks out now i also want
to bring on my colleague
john from obesetobeast who also made a
video about this particular concept
and the article that i referenced so i
wanted to get his perspective
as well first of all john i did want to
apologize
i really am sorry i know i told you this
on email and i honestly did not
ever mean to insult you or make you feel
stupid
i have a lot of respect for you and for
your intelligence
and the fact that you could even read
and respond to that email
live in real time i think says a lot i
i could never do that myself so again
apologies because i
watched that video live right on stream
and i had no idea what to expect
and i think for me like i said it later
in the live stream
was like i don't think you're malicious
in in what you were saying
but i was just responding with my gut
feeling right for me i grew up in
special ed and stuff and you hear the
word struggle
all the time like you just hear it and
it becomes this word of like
oh you know what i'm saying if you
didn't struggle with that
you are a genius like
you obviously have experience living in
a larger body i mean
obese to beast that's that's your whole
platform do you think that body
positivity would have been helpful to
you
then it's an interesting question and i
don't want to say it's it's like one of
those ones where it's more on the grayer
i don't want to say yes and i don't want
to say no
because i know where i was at at 20
years old i was almost 400 pounds
i struggled a lot with just being afraid
of god that was the main reason why i
decided
decided to try and lose weight so it
wasn't really even a i'm not happy with
my body and that's why i'm losing weight
because i want to change it right it was
like i
i was 20 years old afraid to be home
alone because i was like what if
something happens and no one's here
right it was
less oh i'm i wish i could shop at more
stores and more i'm genuinely afraid of
of what's going to happen in in a month
or what's going to happen in five years
i'm not going to say that maybe being a
little bit more happy with where i was
in my body might have made me a little
bit happier but i don't think it would
have
changed the trajectory of the decisions
that i made
to decide to end up losing the weight
now that you are in like what i would
consider a fit socially desirable body
do you think that body positivity as
like as a movement or as a concept
is helpful for you now the words body
positivity mean
something totally different than what
the movement is now so the words body
positivity dude are you kidding me i
think anyone and everyone can
be part of that and can feel empowered
by that because you look at
crazy level athletes and they might have
some stretch marks or they might have
some
some roles that maybe they're not super
happy about right and they can say hey
i'm body positive about this even though
i'm a you know a high level athlete like
it doesn't bother me right but now my
biggest issue
and my biggest struggle is it seems like
body positivity has been taken hold
by a certain group of people and only
certain people are allowed to
say that they are body positive so
there's other words that people will
throw around like body neutrality but i
personally think it's
overly confusing what body positivity
should mean
my first video that got super viral that
like changed my life was me showing my
loose skin after losing 180 pounds okay
so i still have that loose skin and i
still talk about it right i still
call myself body positive and i
personally don't think that
me doing that is taking a is taking body
to positivity away from anyone else what
i struggle with is people like me
are now getting attacked as such a
strong word
but are getting accosted and being told
that we're not allowed to use that
anymore
more than anything it just is so
confusing yes i think everyone should be
body positive i understand where people
are coming from on the other side where
it's not just the words it's more than
meaning but
i just feel like the vast majority of
people aren't going to be able to make
that distinction and understand that
there are
two different things do you feel that
like knowing that historically the body
positive
movement was designed to help liberate
oppressed bodies largely
fat black women do you think that it's
today
it's wrong for others to use the term
i personally don't think that it is i've
seen a lot of different
places claim that they are the start
like they're the reason that body
positivity started i've heard that
i've heard that one a lot like i'm not
i'm not discrediting that at all like
i've heard that a lot but i've also
heard a lot of people say
oh it's it was for burn victims or
people that were amputees that were
missing limbs and they were like you
know body positive because of this but
for me i think what matters now
is where we are in the current space and
like understanding especially
when we look at instagram when we look
at all these social media platforms and
how many people
struggle with not feeling perfect and
the reason they don't feel perfect
is because they are one editing crap out
of their photos
right they might even be getting
surgeries which there's nothing wrong
with that but it's like
if that's if that's the standard that
you are trying to get to
it's like come on man it's just not
realistic so even if there's someone
that's 400 pounds and they see someone
that is maybe in a straight sized body a
body that's more desirable but they're
still struggling with having
roles or having stretch marks like i
think it's crazy that someone that might
be at the bigger end of the spectrum
might feel like
attacked or might feel like they're
being belittled by someone else trying
to feel positive about their body a lot
of it comes down to
comparison and i think that it's people
comparing themselves to others so it's
that person that might be 400 pounds or
might be overweight comparing themselves
to the person that might be in a
straight sized body by being like well
you're not as big as me so you shouldn't
struggle with this but it's like dude
just because they're not as big as you
doesn't mean that they don't have their
own struggles
because then it turns into who is having
the most struggles and then no one
like the biggest problem for me is then
people feel scared
to even say they're struggling with
things like this is something i struggle
with just in a lot of aspects of my life
i've gone through times where i'm afraid
to talk about any of it
because i'm afraid someone's gonna be
like well i don't have a job or well
i do this and i'm like i mean i i i see
that but it doesn't change the fact that
i'm struggling as well yeah
i think those are all really valid
points and i and i totally feel you on
like the
the job thing or other privileges that
we have in our life and how
so often yes we can acknowledge that we
have that privilege
to me it comes down to just like making
a quick like disclaimer you know i
acknowledge my
thin privilege that doesn't mean that
everything is so easy and it doesn't
mean that
you know i i can't acknowledge that i'm
i have those struggles or that i have
those
um hard times so i think those are all
really valid points
okay so that brings me to the honest
thoughts that i previously shared on
who should be using the body positive
label or hashtag i think where i've
landed on this
right now is that a lot of this comes
down to language
and also understanding the difference
between body positivity as a concept and
body positivity as a movement and also
what is the movement's purpose as marc
quiselle mercedes said on the food and
heaven podcast
body positive movement is not about
loving your body
it's about freeing people from
historically rooted
oppression this was something that
previously i don't think i really
fully understood or grasped the concept
of body positivity has evolved
so far from that thanks largely to
social media that even i don't think
that i was fully aware of its original
intent
and if i don't always keep that top of
mind i would assume that the public
seeing these instagram posts of white
thin women using the term
likely don't either i think that yes in
an ideal world we should all be aiming
to love and respect our bodies
oppressed or otherwise we are all
susceptible to
body scrutiny and pressures to look a
certain way
privileged or not i realize that it's
exhausting for us to performatively kind
of love our body
all the damn time that's just not
reality and i also know that in the past
i'd called out blog lottie's for example
for not reading the room
and acknowledging her thin privilege
when talking about her dissatisfaction
with her body
when it is a socially desirable body but
it's now kind of like
gauche to even mention when you're
feeling vulnerable about your body when
it's not a
bad body i've realized that while we can
all feel these things and
even express these feelings because
again we all have these pressures and
diet culture
sucks period it's important that our
voices are not always the loudest and
also that our privilege in this
conversation
is acknowledged so yeah i do feel that
in these cases
a simple disclaimer can really go a long
way you know thin privilege is something
that you know i acknowledge and talk
about
regularly on this channel so much so
that some people have
called me out on it thinking that it's
total bs it's not bs
but whiteness is another privilege that
i do believe i need to acknowledge more
often
that's definitely something that i'm
personally working on
now most importantly i want to say that
while i think it's important that we
all work towards respecting our body and
fostering positive beliefs about our
body
even communicating that if you are thin
and a white influencer
it's also important to knowledge that
it's a hell of a lot easier for someone
like me to find
body positivity without a movement
behind me to support me
when my body is praised by society by
default
the marginalized bodies for whom the
body positivity movement was originally
intended for
do not have that same privilege so for
those of us who
do live in privileged socially desirable
bodies that is thin white and able we
maybe need to
take a step back from the body
positivity movement
to allow its original intended
benefactors to shine we can
and we should still be allies and still
support the tenets of body positivity
when it comes to our use of the movement
for our personal gain
let's say for marketing it perhaps needs
to come with a different name
a colleague of mine rebecca scritchfield
uses body kindness for example
other ideas are body neutrality our body
respect body love body freedom body
confidence
these might better articulate what we
stand for without encroaching on
someone else's really important
territory okay so moving on and again
a reminder that this video is not a
response to the article
um i actually had other messages in the
original video that i want to articulate
so i do want to repeat them again here
because
they help to express my professional
views
and how they've ultimately evolved over
time i do not believe that
all intentional weight loss efforts or
changes in diet
with a desire to lose weight are
examples of disordered eating
poor body image hating your body or
mental instability i
do not think that diets intrinsically
lead to eating disorders there are
subsets of the population for whom
engaging in any kind of purposeful
restriction is going to be problematic
and unhealthy
physically and or psychologically but
there are also a lot of people
who can count calories or get on the
scale every week or cut out certain food
groups or use a dieting app
without it impacting their mental health
they can do these things for periods of
time
and then you know let them go when they
aren't working for them rather than
obsessed the point
of it taking over their life so if you
find that
some of these things work for you and
this is what improves your physical and
emotional health and
sense of happiness then you should feel
empowered
not ashamed to do these things now
second
being fat does not mean you're unhealthy
but we do have evidence to suggest that
excess weight can play a role in some
health issues blood pressure blood
sugars
joint pain infertility heart disease
cancer risk kidney and liver disease
sleep disorders etc like i said before
to deny this would be an insult to
people with this lived experience and
also to the research
but weight is just one variable or risk
factor for
any disease and thin people suffer from
these diseases
all the time as well however thin people
are often offered
alternative treatments that fat people
are not
because the medical system tends to see
a large body and just sends that patient
away to change it so a lot of
haze proponents will say that the data
linking weight to disease is due to
weight stigma in the health care system
and therefore poor medical care i would
say yes
that is absolutely happening and it
probably does
play a devastating role but i don't
think that the excess weight itself
is completely benign across the board so
i think unfortunately we see a potential
health problem
aka being overweight turn into a larger
health problem
when equitable and fair health care
isn't accessed
third i've said this before in my video
here but i believe in meeting people
where they are
even though i know that most people who
try to lose weight will
gain it back statistically if this is
what an individual wants to do
i fully respect that and i can get on
board i fully
appreciate why anyone would want to lose
weight especially
because living in a larger body in an
aesthetically driven society
is surely really uncomfortable so i
think it's important that as a nutrition
professional who ultimately
wants to help people that i hold space
for those conversations
rather than just shut them down and push
them out and while my approach will
always be to focus on
health promoting behaviors while letting
the weight kind of do what it will
i think it's still important to work
with a client
and to work with their goals and finally
to reiterate and of course conclude
as i have no lived experience in a
marginalized body the body positivity
movement
is not for me to use for personal gain
and again while i haven't really made
body positive be part of my personal
marketing i agree that
some of us maybe should refrain from
monetizing from it by calling ourselves
body positive dietitians body freedom
dietitians body confidence dietitians
great but maybe we just have to mute our
use of that hashtag
to let those who it was originally
intended for be heard
so i will make space for those bodies
that need to be uplifted and will
support from the sidelines again i
acknowledge we all have body struggles
regardless of size shape or race
and all of those struggles are valid but
we create our own movement to explore
these
while leaving the body positive movement
to those who need it most whether that
be
those who are fat black lgbtq disabled
or other
marginalized populations so friends i
think that's where i'm at and i'm not
done
i'm still learning and my opinions and
beliefs will probably change again it
would be a lot easier for me
to not address these issues or to like
pull the wool over my eyes and pretend
this is not an issue but it's obviously
weighing on me heavily and i think it's
a really important discussion to have i
mean the youtube wellness space
shouldn't just be about vegan smoothie
bowls and
keto fat bombs we need to be talking
real issues
too and on that note that is all that i
have for you guys today
i really really really want to hear what
you have to say and also please be
kind in the comments this one was
admittedly
a really hard one for me to articulate
because i often feel
really vulnerable being in the middle of
what i often see
as opposing ideologies you know the haze
folks and the weight loss folks but if
you like this video please be sure to
give it
the thumbs up and also check out the
links to some of the folks i interviewed
today below
and i'm also going to be sharing a list
of larger bodied or bipod creators below
so that you can check that out
in your own time also subscribe to the
channel and i will see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye